Sự dung thè, tay khoản dấu thông không đúng quy định,
căn thiệp làm dả giữ liệu thành phản định từ sẽ bị sự phản nghiệm theo nghị định mới của chính phụ
áp dùng từ tháng 3 năm 2020.
chính phụ vừa bán hành nghị định số 3 xấu, quy định sự phản vi phạp hành chính trong lính vực đường bộ
có hiệu lực từ ngày 1,5 năm 2020.
Nhi định bộ xung nhiều trái tài, nhằm sết chặt hoạt động thu ví và tinh dồin vận tài.
Theo đó, các hành vi rắn lành trong thành phản định từ sau thông như
tự ý chuyển thể đầu quý dự các phương tiền,
phá huy, làm dạ hoặc soa sức liệu thè,
mở hoặc suy chỉ tài khoản dấu thông nặng sang, mạo sang,
sẽ bị phạp từ ba đến năm trở động đối với cá nhân,
từ sau đến mười trở động đối với tổ chức.
Nếu vì phạm nghiêm trọng hơn như sâm nhập hệ thống thành phản định từ sau thông đường bộ,
phá hoại đánh cấp dữ liệu làm thây đồ trái phép phần mềm,
giữ liệu diện tử, khoặc phát hành trứng tử thu ví không đúng đối tượng giá chỉ có thể bị phạp từ mười đến hai mơ chỗ đồng.
Nhi định cũng quy định sự phát các hành vi vv phạm trong kinh dành bận tài hành khách.
Lại xét thặc xí dành lận cơ không sự dụng thích bị tính tiền,
bị phát đến hai chỗ đồng và bộng lộp lại khoản thu lợi bất hợp pháp.
Sơn nhập, lại xét, từ chối trở hành khách đámu vẻ,
thu tiền cao hơn giá nghiêm ít, khoặc vi phạm quy định phục của hành khách trên xe biết sẽ tuyên của định,
cũng bị sự phát theo các bất tưởng, các quy định mới nhằm tăng kỳ cường,
mình bạn trong hạt động thu ví và vận tài đường bộng.